tout a commencé par la rencontre entre
alexia et jonathan ruiz était très jeune
en 2005 elle avait 16 ans et lui 21 ans
et on apprend que c'est elle qui a fait
le premier pas quand ça s'est concrétisé
regarde il a quatre ans de plus qu'elle
est 100 m sila tombe son charme
instantanément c'est elle qui va faire
le premier pas et qui va l'embrasser
à sa grande surprise puisqu'il pense pas
du tout l'intéressé ou me n'étant pas du
tout séducteur il se retrouve un peu
happé par cette jeune fille très très
joli très très solaire qui l'a donc ce
qu'il a choisi quelque part on la voit
on l'entend elle parle clair et lui pas
voilà donc il ya deux portraits qui
finalement sont assez différents l'un
par rapport à l'autre mais ça fonctionne
quand même assez rapidement après
effectivement ses vacances au ski elle
avait 16 ans et lui 21 ans quand ils se
sont rencontrés
on a l'impression que quand on écoute ce
récit que voilà il cessé de dire déjà ça
démarre et ballon entre les deux cc
c'est que c'est curieux c'est vrai que
tout le monde et cette voix là de donner
son avis sur cette affaire un droit
alors non on ne peut pas dire que le
couple a mal démarré entre alexia
johnattan bien au contraire puisque
alexiens avait 16 ans quand elle
rencontre et johnatan donc c'est vrai
que quand on y est
quand on a cet âge là on est plutôt fier
d'être un garçon plus âgé donc lancé un
couple départ qui en harmonie c'est si
vous voulez quand alexia a évolué et
qu'elle a eu des attentes de femmes ou
là il ya un écart qui s'est creusé au
sein du couple
mais au départ tout va bien entre alors
douze ans plus tard c'est le drame
jonathan tu alexia bien sûr l'image la
plus forte de cette affaire celle qui a
marqué tout le monde ce sont les larmes
de jonathan d'aval lors de la marche
blanche organisée en hommage à sa femme
quel plus coton plus tard on apprendra
que c'est lui le meurtrier
passion qui nous réunit c'est la force
de notre couple il faudrait nous
dépasser dans nos sorties et dans notre
vie commune
cette plénitude ne manquera terriblement
voilà alors c'est quand on voit ces
images s'accroît comme il a pu aller
aussi loin m ça dépend ce que vous
entendez par comment at il pu elle aussi
loin ça dépend de la façon dont vous
analysez vous appréhender ses larmes
c'est ce qu'il a commencé qu'il est dans
la commune i qu'ils jouent un rôle
effectivement on peut avoir une analyse
tout à fait lapidaire sur à m'aimer mais
pour connaître la chose criminelle et la
difficulté de la chose criminels et de
celui qui est il ya passé le cap de la
chose criminel c'est à dire qui a tué
ici je pense que personne ne peut le
comprendre même pas nous qui le
pratiquons tous les jours je pense aussi
que s'il ya des gars des larmes sincères
il ya aussi un certain accablement faut
pas oublier qu'on était sur un meurtre
pas un assassinat c'est à dire que on
passe sur un coup de sang de quelqu'un
qui n'avait jamais été violent qui passe
dans le côté du crime et dieu sait que
c'est pas un cas isolé malheureusement
et cette touche toutes les classes
sociales
on le voit très fréquemment
effectivement à partir de ce moment là
je pense que il ya plusieurs choses qui
se mélangent on veut retenir uniquement
le ski est facile c'est à dire la
manipulation le mensonge et larmes de
crocodile je me rappelle d'une une
discussion que j'avais vu dominer crise
et qui regarde et c'est l'armée qui me
disait tu sais effectivement je pense
qu'il peut être sincère à ce moment là
voilà donc c'est un mélange de tout les
choses criminelle sauf pour les
criminels endurcis les criminels averti
les criminels de métier ça existe là on
est sur quelqu'un qui a tué et qui du
jour au lendemain a dû gérer cette chose
là avec un autre sentiment très humain
ne pas se faire prendre
alors je comprends que ça puisse
horrifié que ça puisse dégoûté que ça
puisse en fait mais c'est très humain
tout ça il fallait qu'ils continuent ce
sont il ya deux choses
il fallait il fallait aussi que que non
seulement il continue son rôle mais je
pense qu'il était très difficile pour
lui de décevoir tout le monde a avoué
que c'était de lui c'était dire à sa
ferme à sa famille à sa belle famille
qui l'adoré 1 cc c'est un lien presque
filial celui en qui vous croyais à
martine sa mère celui en qui tu crois
celui en qui perd tout espoir celui que
tu imagines être quelqu'un de parfait
l'agent qui s incarner et bien ce jeu
là c'est transformer en meurtrier ultra
violent et c'est moi faire tomber ce
masque c'était compliqué ça a pris du
temps ça a été très difficile c'était
jean marc laurent qui lisait un canton
nasa sur l'estomac
ça doit être difficile à sortir une
question que posait justement comment on
devient l'avocat de jonathan naval s'est
passé est ce que c'est vrai que c'est on
sait pas comment comment vous avez été
choisi parce que c'est mal mais non ça
ben on est très habituellement choisis
en matière criminelle c'est vrai sacré
avocat parisien donc on n'est pas
surpris nous d'être choisi pour défendre
john m daval on défend beaucoup
d'affaires entre parenthèses qu'on
qualifie de féminicide on défend aussi
beaucoup de femmes
enfin moi mais de femmes qui ont aussi
tué et qui sont passés à l'acte c'est
existe bien tôt ou rendez vous aviez
donc c'est un peu naturel si vous voulez
que c'est un peu comme un médecin
spécialiste
qu'on vienne nous voir c'est un peu
naturel après jean marc florand et
quelqu'un aussi avec qui j'étais très
proche parce que une pratique la même
matière et qui très vite a pensé à nous
en disant voilà jeu j'aimerais bien vous
soyez avec moi dans le dossier parce que
je préfère garder la famille avec les
liens du sang je préfère que vous
gardiez de nate henn peut-être
connaissance jean marc florand est
quelqu'un de très brillant s'est il dit
c'était plus prudent on cgem vous aviez
suivi la sphère vont être saisis de
l'affairé non pas du tout regarde très
peu la télé d'accord vous de quoi la
faire sécher les découvertes de un jour
avant d'être contacté par jean marc
florand j'étais en stage en guadeloupe
je regarde cette a8 je vois cette
affaire je me dis il est intéressant ce
dossier mais le lendemain le téléphone
sonne d'accord elle comme ça que j'ai
découvert la soeur de lamine d'accord
oui gilles verdez vous parliez de
masques qui tombent pour jonathan d'aval
à un moment est-ce que vous avez joué un
rôle justement pour qu'il faille de
l'armure en lui disant un moment les
mensonges c'est plus possible là il faut
avouer
monsieur vous ne ferez jamais avoué
quelqu'un qui veut pas vous c'est à dire
que le plus gros du travail
c'est lui qui le fait le le rôle de
l'avocat n'est pas de devenir vous dire
ceci n'est pas une table c'est un
aquarium c'est suicidaire
c'est un peu la théorie de landru mai
mais le rôle d'un avocat cdd et parfois
aussi de conseiller
dans des chemins qui peuvent paraître
difficiles mais qui sont les seuls
chemins qui permet d'arriver à une juste
peine depuis le début depuis le premier
jour on défende de matane d'aval
certains n'ont pas compris il y en a qui
pensaient qu on l'accablé en est ce que
objectivement il y avait des éléments de
preuve totalement confondant dans le
dossier il valait mieux affronter la
vérité parce que les enjeux étaient très
lourds les anges et enfin 2 en fin de
parcours
nous ce qui nous intéressait c le procès
c'est une boucle tout ça ces trois ans
de travail c'était sortir de la
perpétuité passe quand on aurait trouvé
que c'était injuste pour sa personnalité
son personnage
après je comprends que dans
l'immédiateté un peu comme les larmes
ont comprennent pas toujours ce qu'on
fait ce que font les avocats les avocats
pénalistes mais je vous dirais qu
accompagner sur le chemin des aveux un
accusé ça fait aussi partie de notre
mission faire acquitter un innocent ça
fait aussi partie de notre mission mais
c'est compliqué je pense que tous les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent on va
revenir au dossier du jour mais tous les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
doivent être passionné par ce que vous
dites mais juste on se dira un moment
comment ça se passe entre ses avocats et
ceux coupables voilà est-ce qu'à un
moment il vous il fond en larmes il vous
dit ben là c'est moi comment ça se passe
quelle est votre relation avec lui parce
que et quand il se passe un peu que me
comme dans beaucoup de métiers on sent
les choses vous sentez les choses qui
ont un plateau je pense qu'on en est là
avait a toujours d'ailleurs une approche
très vous disiez contre vous disais
c'est lui on sait que c'est lui mais il
un moment et où que bazini le nom au
départ en fait si on voulait avant que
jonathan soit interpellé et placé en
garde à vue
il y avait une fuite il y avait en fait
à un article lu une presse locale où
l'article est apparue sur le net le mari
d'alexia placé en garde à vue
donc nous reçoit johnattan on lui dit
voilà et un article qui est sorti cet
article il est pas sorti pour rien
monsieur d'aval c'est qu'à un moment et
peut-être pas se passer quelque chose
il sort de notre cabinet et on se
regarde on dit c'est pas lui non oui on
s'en est voulu d'avoir pensé un instant
que c'était lui ce que parce que il faut
le connaître un nounou on approche fou
ce que vous dites
mais vous savez c'est pas parce que
c'est celui qu'on à ostraciser qu'on a
montré du doigt en le traitant de
monstres qu'on a consumé nous on ne le
juge pas nous sommes ses avocats on ne
cautionne pas un bien sûr qu'on ne
défend pas le crime de fiona tan qu'on
défende johnatan d'aval ce qui est très
différent et est donc on l'a proches
sans jugement comme sa mère et à partir
de ce moment là il se livre sous un
visage sous une façon d'être que le
public ne ne connaît pas voilà et le
procès n'a pas permis de bien évidemment
de révéler cette phase de john athènes
parce qu'il était totalement inhibé par
l'angoissé par la présence des autres
faut pas oublier non plus il est seul
depuis trois ans il s'est retrouvé dans
une cour d'assises entouré plein de gens
voilà c'était une épreuve difficile
c'est un coupable je sais que tu vas là
c'est une épreuve qui s'est imposé à lui
une haine mais voilà je jeu pour nous je
pense que son procès a permis de
redonner aussi cette part d'humanité de
le sortir de l'ostraciser à sion qu'on
avait été à quel moment vous vous êtes
dit tous les deux a contrario c'est lui
c'est quand un moment le jour il est
placé en garde à vue
finalement on découvre des éléments
objectifs
on n'avait pas que c'est jusqu'à présent
d'accord et là on commence à saisir le
pneu le drap le tracker ça commence à
faire beaucoup
le tracker se fait du mal mais c'est ça
c'est tracker qui est un moment vous lui
dites ça lui le tracker ça fait du mal
vous lui dites adieu à jouer
l'intervalle vous dites là on est non
non on lui dit rien parce que nous on
n'a pas ces informations là d'accord
c'est sort dans la presse nous on les
apports c'est les gendarmes qui lui
disait john allen de même nous on
apprend tout ça au travers de la presse
c'est assez extraordinaire cette garde à
vue où on apprend les éléments à charge
dans la presse et les fuites inquiets
urnes et pour organiser la défense de
jonathan d'aval à un moment vous avez
une discussion avec lui oui tu coûtes un
moment il faut que tu nous disent des
choses ou pas du tout je sous le
contrôle d'un en est là à chaque fois de
johnatan laval a évolué dans la
manifestation de la vérité sur ce chemin
de la vérité
à chaque fois ça s'est fait de façon
très très calme et on l'avait toujours
dit
c'est vous qui décidez maintenant où
vous parlez où vous ne parlez pas c'est
à vous de le faire
on lui avait toujours laissé le contrôle
on travaille ensemble on ne travaille
pas contre johnattan d'aval on travaille
ensemble parce que on savait où on
voulait en en arrivait dans son affaire
effectivement c'est lui qui va quand
même prendre la décision et je peux vous
assurer quand vous avez un criminel qui
a tué qui est coupable mais qui est
retors qui a un esprit beaucoup plus
compliqué beaucoup plus pernicieux si
vous voulez et bien jamais jamais dans
sa réflexion il n'arrivera ou et
certaines choses jamais dans sa
réflexion il n'arrivera à dire à des
gens voilà ce que j'ai fait voilà la
vérité de cet instant on a l'impression
qu'il a avoué qu'il a jamais réussi à te
dire ça et c'est il a dit en trois
étapes ça a été très difficile il a dit
elles sont été les élections la garde à
vue
regarde exactement 5 milliard de vues et
la confrontation aussi avec isabelle
fouillot un bon on a beaucoup dont on a
beaucoup parlé
et puis à la reconstitution parce que à
la fin de la confrontation rester le
point de la crémation dans laquelle il
s'était pas expliquer et au moins de la
reconstitution finalement il est
expliqué de l'intégralité des choses et
ce devant toutes les personnes qu'il
aimait y compris la famille d'ali qui
est fait est très compliqué le jeu le
plus dur c'était de reconnaître la
crémation
c'était que c'était ça le plus difficile
vous l'avez vu craquer ou un moment ou
pas du tout moi j'ai cru qu'il allait
s'effondrer à la reconstitution
on l'a vu s'effondrer à la confrontation
fallait vivre ces moments là la
confrontation vous savez quand c'est la
réalité un isabelle flou pour en prendre
c'est brad johnatan gavalda de la mer
leur ensemble
j'étais très proches et on voit on voit
cette image quand il l'apprend danse on
a on a presque l'impression nous c'est
pas des images ainsi on sent
l'électricité on sent le bon sens qui se
passe quelque chose que personne aucun
professionnel aguerri un an dans cette
salle n'a jamais vu ses ces voix là
c'est parce qu'il est particulier parce
qu'elle est particulière c'est parce
qu'il n'ya pas que des défauts c'est
parce qu'il y avait aussi beaucoup de
qualité malheureusement il ya eu ça
alors tu as eu à beaucoup de gens qui
demandent quelle est la différence entre
meurtres assassinats
elle est profond de l'assassinât c'est
une préméditation c'est une réflexion et
qui dit réflexion dit dans le chemin
criminels bien évidemment une résolution
criminelle très différente c'est
j'envisage je prépare jeu je passe à
l'acte alors que le coup de sang vous
m'agacer mon cher série lh je vous
bouscule vous mettez un coup de poing où
vous prenez un couteau qui est sur la
table vous mettez un coup or moi je vois
tu sois pas là qu'ils vont me tuer on
sait jamais hein c je vous laisserai une
carte mais non mais ça c'est le coup de
sang et ça c'est l'homicide
oui il ya une profonde différence
qu'entre si je rentre je prépare je vous
regarde et je viens vous porter un coup
de couteau
donc la résolution criminelle n'est pas
la même et les personnalités criminels
ne sont pas les mêmes c'est très
différent comment comment on prépare un
procès comme celui de jonathan d'aval
quand vous avez toutes les preuves
contre lui vous dit comment vous dites
on va plaider quoi le meurtre ah oui
voilà on abat après c'est vrai que sur
le plan juridique au long du procès 11
finalement c'était cette question là qui
s'imposait on savait que ce qu'on savait
que j'ai jean portejoie cathy richard
souhaitait demander la requalification
en assassinat d'accord way avec ornella
samuel est elle avait dix gadenne on
était toute une équipe
trois avocats une juriste pour monter ce
dossier là et un médecin le docteur éric
premier qui me qui nous a beaucoup aidés
notamment sur tout le côté médical
donc on avait déjà préparé tout le
dossier pour anticiper ce qui allait
arriver c'est à dire nous opposer
l'assassinât l'empoisonnement le viol
post mortem
donc ça en était un surfer salaire que
vous avez vous avez découvert des choses
en plus à chaque fois le premier jour du
procès on nous parle d'un viol post
mortem à la part de joe natale navale
chose qui n'avait jamais été évoqué
pendant toutes les années d'instruction
donc c'est vrai qu'on a on sort ça le
premier jour du procès bon ben voilà on
a passé beaucoup de temps
mauvaise humeur et là on bascule dans on
n'est déjà pas là dans le drame
mais là on bascule dans le sordide du
sordide le blog
blog si vous voulez le le rapport sexuel
post mortem dans l'inconscient populaire
on est dans plus que l'object si bien
roulé et basculé dans perpétuité demandé
une sentiment constamment qu'on voulait
nous faire basculer dans perpétuité
alors que au début il y avait un
discours qui était très clair qu'il est
dire on veut la vérité mais mais tant
mieux mais après on a eu l'impression
qu'on voulait plus que la vérité j'ai eu
le sentiment je crois quand elle a eu
aussi qu' on voulait noircir johnattan
pour d'aisé mais celui qu'on avait aimé
le plus à ce qu'on avait trop aimé il
faut il fallait vraiment qu'ils
deviennent absolument abjecte pour
accepter le sentiment que j'ai pour ce
que les téléspectateurs ont le même
sentiment
ce soir en direct parce que nos
témoignages et incroyable 1 franchement
juste on a l'impression que même vous
vous avez été vous ne les lis berner par
jonathan vous avez vous l'avez plaira
doré au départ vous êtes dit c'est pas
lui c'est c'est pas possible donc on se
dit il est quand même très très fort
parce que même vous quand vous apprenez
même des choses derrière on parlait du
viol le post mortem ou dit c'est pas
possible il n'a pas pu faire ça mais
vous dans l'impression qu'ils vous
l'avez pas aimer mais vous l'avez vous
avez beaucoup apprécié comme sa belle
famille qui les met à mont louis en loi
il était excité j'ai bu ils ont eu un
canton d'arzacq sentiment que la belle
famille ils ont eu deux deux morts mine
de rien exactement ils ont eu leur fille
et celui qu'ils considéraient comme leur
fils parce que ça a été un traumatisme
pour eux deux traumatismes en fait l'un
après l'autre
il nie mais tellement il aimait
tellement ce garçon et c'est vrai que
même vous vous s'en va là on sent que au
début vous a séduit mais en fait nous
johnattan je pense que je peux parler
aussi à anton
c'est un garçon qu'on apprécie on ne
parle pas au passé c'est un garçon
réellement voilà un garçon à qui guy de
leur clocher est un homme saoul un homme
c'est vrai c'est vrai 50 l'a reproché
c'est un homme qui voit là pour qui on
est on sait attaché au moins way maman
car seulement c'est quelqu'un
d'attachant qui est une personnalité
attachante on ne réduit pas à ces
quelques minutes de cet acte parce que
c'est un garçon qui a eu une vie pendant
33 ans où finalement on n'a pas eu grand
chose à lui reprocher moment sécher ses
trois premières années qu'est ce donc
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans sa tête
dans la tête de jonathan dalle vous
faisiez tenir moment c'est sûr qu'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est compliqué on va
pas refaire tout le procès mais vous
voyez ornella disais quand johnatan
rencontre alexia john fn il a des toques
quand il rencontre alexia c'est elle qui
fait qui va vers lui c'est elle qui
l'appelle pour l'invitation
d'anniversaire il ne comprend même pas
qu'à l'excellent s'intéresse à lui
elle est magnifique à l'excepté pour
vous dire l'image qu'il a de lui c'est
sa très jolie fille mais lui ne conçois
même pas qu'une jolie fille puisse le
regarder quand elle l'invite à son
anniversaire c'est elle qui l'embrassent
c'est elle qui sera avec lui vous voyez
sur la photo là il va en quelques mois
perdre tous ses tocs il va trouver une
assurance extraordinaire il va commencer
à bien s'habiller il va commencer à
prendre soin de lui ce qu'il n'avait
jamais essayé va commencer à avoir
l'amour propre de l'estimé de soi et
tout ça va être portée jusqu'à un moment
où tout va s'effondrer quand le couple
va connaître des difficultés difficultés
pour avoir un enfant puis des
difficultés pour avoir des rapports
sexuels est une réalité du dossier du
canadien
et alors que dans les coups on voulait
il ya des hauts et des bas peu importe
toujours est il que pour lui il va vivre
ça comme une souffrance absolue s'est
effondré près et puis alexia ce qui va
lui reproche aussi va en parler aux amis
le meilleur ami par exemple est au
courant que par exemple un soir ils ont
un rapport sexuel
elles préviennent meilleur ami par sms
en lui disant ça y est enfin il a réussi
ça devient compliqué je pense que il ya
beaucoup de choses pour l'expliquer aux
en tout cas en cour d'assises les choses
ont été assez lisible pour des jurés
comment un homme qui est affable qui ne
posent aucun problème qui est quelqu'un
de gentil va un moment magazine et
emmagasiner fait cocotte-minute on
parlait un expert et puis un moment
explosé et là il ya deux choses 1 soit
c'est les violences conjugales
soit c'est hors de contrôle et on passe
en 5 10 minutes de vous et moi au
criminel voilà donc et je crois que
celui qui qui qui qui passent à l'acte
n'a pas beaucoup d'explications après je
vais vous dire une chose ce qui était
intéressant aujourd'hui c'est ce que
disait le prénom de la cour d'assises il
ya un effet avec l'hyper médiatisation
qui était beaucoup critiqué
mais enfin ceux qui la critiquent sont
toujours aussi des gens très médiatique
d'ailleurs il ya aussi un côté
pédagogique
oui c'est nous qui pratiquons beaucoup
les affaires criminelles on se dit des
fois c'est terrible quand même parce que
si les gens parler si les gens étaient
un peu plus éduqués notamment sur les
ruptures sur la notion d' abandon sur la
notion de vide qu'on peut avoir quand
l'autre s'en va sur la notion comment
traiter l'autre comment le percevoir
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'on appelle la
réification de l'autre est ce que
l'autre nous appartient ou pas eh bien
comment gérer une rupture
ce sont en fait on se rend compte que
beaucoup de gens vivent sans se poser
aucune question
il avance tout droit et un moment quand
y'a un coup de frein ils prennent le mur
et c'est après qu'ils réfléchissent et
après quand qu'il réfléchit souvent
quand vous parlez à des gens qui sont
passés à l'acte qui sont passés dans le
monde criminel il vous dit si seulement
je m'étais arrêté j'avais réfléchi un
peu je serai pas là j'ai tué par exemple
la mère de ma fille je aujourd'hui je me
rends compte que j'ai tué ma mère de ma
fille on a ça il vous l'a dit ça
jonathan non qu'est-ce qui n'avait pas
d'enfant c'est à dire et xavier hamon il
a essayé
il a essayé d'avoir johnatan comme celle
entre entreprendre je ne sais plus
comment on appelle ça une sorte de
thérapie conjugale
parce qu'il avait conscience qu'il avait
besoin de parler que ces problèmes
n'étaient pas que mécanique d'abord il
ait pas de problèmes mécaniques
c'est un sportif marathonien c'était
psychologique un charme je n'avais
jamais eu de près mécanique en réalité
mais il avait un blocage profond
psychologique
oui beaucoup plus handicapant que
physique d'ailleurs et il a essayé de
parler à martin qui se sent veut parce
qu'elle nous a dit je pour moi tout
allait bien et vous savez vous dit les
larmes
il faisait bien semblant tout le monde a
été pris à son jeu alexia personne n'a
vu qu'elle était en tout cas dans sa
famille qu'elle était malheureuse sa
mère n'a jamais vu qu'elle était en
pleine détresse que son mariage battait
de l aile sûr que ce que cet homme
n'était plus l'homme qu'elle aimait on
était au bord de la rupture
à ce moment là et pourtant les deux
donné cette image du bonheur on a
l'impression qu'ils plaques est une
sorte de bonheur imposé voyez sa barbie
et ken
mais c'est ça et c'est ça en fait la
maison le chien larnod 25 vous êtes en
train de dire voilà c'est ça c'est que
pour lui cette image idyllique s'est
effondré et là il a basculé
je crois qu'il pouvait pas accepter que
ça ces fonds c'est ça ouais et le fait
qu'elle en parle à des personnes c'est
ça qui a fait qu'ils qu'il appliquait
passe à l'acte alors vous saurez sous le
contrôle d'ornellas que quand elle
parlait ses amis elle disait voilà je
suis pas heureuse je suis malheureuse
mon mari a peur de moi je ça ne va pas
mais je m'en fous je vois là je l'aimais
je reste quoi qu'il arrive je l'aimé je
reste d'accord donc je pense que de leur
part ils simple ce couple qui avait été
très heureux et est devenu une prison
voilà et ni l'un ni l'autre n'avait le
courage de s'échapper de cette prison
des deux côtés
malheureuse pour autant elle envisager
de faire un enfant avec center voilà
c'est ça alors aujourd'hui un autre
volet de la faire c'est jouer puisque la
famille de la victime demande et plus de
750 mille euros pour préjudice
d'affection ce qu'on peut expliquer à
nos téléspectateurs
alors effectivement les parents d'alexia
ainsi que la soeur et le beau frère dany
kia ont formulé différentes demandes
qu'il préjudice d'affection qui est la
souffrance endurée suite à la perte
d'alexia et c'est vrai que les sommes
qui ont été sollicités n'osant je peux
le dire littéralement surpris en 765
750000 euros ils ont demandé s'est
jamais vu avant vraiment pratique
régulièrement la matière criminelle on
n'avait jamais vu de cela des barèmes
exactement qui sont comment voulez
habituellement fixée
c'est à dire que voilà c'est un comble
et une vigueur c'est papon bien joué on
a démis stand il n'y a pas de montant
qui indemnise une vie vous laisser c'est
le prix de l'achat 30 si vous voulez et
un parent qui perd un enfant
habituellement ses trente quarante mille
euros si vous voulez
là on était à cent cinquante mille euros
par part en donc on était vraiment dans
des cette source de compte mais louis
parent si on prend par exemple madame
fouillouse voilà trente quarante mille
euros c'est plus ou moins les sommes qui
sont alloués on est à cent cinquante
mille euros pour madame fourneaux oui
j'ai ouï mais excusez moi il y avait
quand même dans cet argent parce que
c'est une allure en argent la douleur la
tristesse le poids du mensonge aussi
tout quoi médiatique aussi le lobby
médiatique tout ce qu'ils ont ce grand
duraclass homme est aussi un oui et
quand on sait que l affaire était
tellement médiatisé on a tellement vu
les parents daley d'alexia que forcément
ça a joué et c'est pour ça que la somme
est très importante parce que ça me
demandez vous avez dit vous les avez
tellement vu mais finalement ils ont
participé ont fait qu'on les voit aussi
oui après après sur la marche sur la
languette il était là il était là
c'était et s'était filmé donc il était
là mais après ils ont fait juste ils
sont finis interview sur bfm
mais c'est vrai que je pense que c'est
ce qui a joué aussi non non mais qui
demande énormément de l'argent non
monsieur nous vous avez passé tout à
l'heure un extrait de 2,2 2,5 4 épisodes
la série d'aval bien sûr qu'ils y ont
participé
oui ce que j'ai dit sur bfm sur x 7 à 8
ils ont fait un certain nombre
d'émissions france 2 etc
moi je ne critique pas le fait de deux
participer jusqu'à la mort et à la chose
médiatique bien sûr et d'ailleurs ils
peuvent avoir des messages
ils peuvent aussi vouloir porter haut et
fort effectivement le souvenir d'alexia
je n'y vois aucun nombre âge
après ce qui m'interpelle ce serait un
peu comme nous de venir vous lire demain
dans la main on est passé à la télé hier
soir bon arrêtons l'hypocrisie et on
n'est pas obligé de passer à la télé il
y avait cent des gens qui refusent de
passer à la télé après on s'en prévaloir
comme d'un préjudice à part entière me
paraît quelque chose de
d'ailleurs la cour d'assises a rejeté
aujourd'hui elle a dit non non vous y
avaient participé
on ne conteste pas votre souffrance que
tout à fait lécher leur joie c'est ça
comme disait monsieur montée non c'est
pas le prix d'une vie qu'on a démis il
faut savoir de combat que j'ai
l'impression en lisant ce que disait des
gens qui ne comprennent pas combien vaut
une vie non mais
vie n'est pas quantifiable c'est le prix
de la douleur et des assiettes doloriste
c'est que je voulais dire que ça 6 mm un
prix est-ce qu'on n'a rien trouvé
d'autre voilà on traduit sans en argent
ça ne veut pas dire grand chose en
réalité ça me ça n'efface pas le chasser
mais pensions alors il a été finalement
admis l'année on le fera versant 165
millions euros jonathan d'aval vous avez
des nouvelles de jonathan d'avis qu'il
est serviable
bien sûr non non non pas les payer mais
ça on verra ça oui c'est pas trop est-ce
que vous avez des nouvelles de jonathan
de vol oui on en est aujourd'hui parce
qu'on a rencontré sa maman martine qui
lui rend régulièrement visite puisque
johnattan a été transféré il a quitté la
maison d'arrêt de dijon
donc là il est dans un centre va dire
d'exaltation et prades les places
seulement ça
il est plus l isolement en effet depuis
quelques semaines désormais côtoient
d'autres des coûts et ça se passe très
très bien
ça se passe très très bien parce que
john athènes c'était très compliqué
finalement la médiatisation a impliqué
dans l isolement
le fait que les seuls contacts qu'il
avait 7 et sa famille nous et puis les
agents de l'administration pénitentiaire
mais c'est vrai que pendant trois années
pas avoir de relation c'est quand même à
face il paraît qu'ils aient un
comportement irréprochable mais ça fera
parvenir non bien sûr que non on s'en
fout qu'il soit ces [ __ ] wee cc c'est
l'horreur du trou bleu
voilà donc la justice il a pris donc 25
ans ou comment ça va se passer
concrètement aventis comporte bien avec
les remises de peine il sort ici là ou
bien il ya il a pris 25 ans sans période
de sûreté ce défaut d'accord c'est
notamment la raison pour laquelle on n'a
pas fait appel
je peux m'en bats je veux non qu'est ce
que je voulais dire lent parce que tout
à l'heure vous avez parlé du circuit du
programme français nous a dit nous ce
qu'on voulait c'est à tout prix éviter à
la perpétuité la perpétuité injuste on
voit ça aurait été injuste qui plane
permettent en fait parce que pris d'un
doute
je vais simplement vous la faire très
très courte mais la perpétuité c'est
quand même réservé à des gens ou sur mu
vous fournirez est décédé il ya pas très
longtemps qu'ils sont plus dans le
criminel mais qu'ils sont vous savez qui
sont vraiment dans l'horreur dans
l'autre chose c'est la fnam et alors
écoutez il ya aussi un discours un peu
un peu stupide pour que le bien existe
il faut que le mal existe dans
l'humanité il y a toujours eu
dès le moment et il y aura toujours eu
des guerres alors je veux bien qu'on ait
un discours complètement édulcoré naïf
ou ou stupide mais peu importe 60 lits
tables des smic
il y aura toujours jusqu'à la fin de
l'humanité des gens qui tueront homme ou
femme
il y aura toujours des gens qui auront
des problèmes pulsionnel et qu'ils
commettront des viols et il y en a
depuis vous remonter les siècles les
journaux au 17e 18e 19e siècle sont
remplies de faits divers tous plus
abominables les uns que les autres
bon ça fait partie de l'être humain il
ya un côté lumineux il ya un côté sombre
il faut l'accepter voilà et quand on est
dans la chose criminelle eh ben on se
rend compte que le côté sombre
le côté criminel le pont se rend compte
que les gens sont parfois beaucoup plus
gris que noir ou blanc il faut pas être
trop manichéen voilà donc moi je trouve
qu'il ya une différence entre francis
hall est forcément celui qui dans un
coup de sang tu ussel et titube sont
énormes mais c'est contré par ans à
perpétuité comme agent pour les parents
pour la salle et moi mais bien sûr s'il
vous plaît contraire il va les faire ses
25 ans non je vais vite mais un an mais
non parce que notre système judiciaire
n'est pas fait de cette façon là il ya
des remises de peine à laurier une loi
qui est en train de revenir mais remises
aux tenants on est plutôt sur un quantum
de peine qui seraient entre 13 et 15